[Musique]
retrouve en cette rentrée dans Paris
direct bonjour Hélène bonjour Damien et
tout d'abord la mine de la presse
l'ouverture donc on disait dans le
journal aujourd'hui à Paris du procès de
l'attentat de Nice du 14 juillet 2016
une attaque qui avait fait on le
rappelle en 86 morts plus de 400 blessés
arrive enfin mais les parties civils
disent déjà ne pas attendre grand chose
de ce process selon 20 minutes qui
rappelle que l'auteur des faits me met
de la ouie je voulais a été abattu par
la police au moment des faits
revendiquer ensuite par le groupe état
islamique l'attentat frappé en masse des
dizaines d'enfants et d'adolescents des
centaines d'autres ont été témoins de
l'horreur s'ils ont après beaucoup
d'entre eux toujours à surmonter leur
traumatisme d'après aujourd'hui en
France
Kenza 4 ans au moment de l'attaque est
toujours suivi après toutes ces années
pour ces troubles de stress
post-traumatique ce soir-là raconte sa
mère dans les colonnes du Parisien kenza
est redevenu un bébé pendant deux ans
elle a dormi sur moi agripper comme un
singe s'ils ont après Damien Kenza se
met encore parfois à faire des centaines
de dessins de camions frénétiquement une
grande fille qui est encore traumatisée
sur le banc des accusés donc on le
disait huit personnes cet homme une
femme des proches de Mohamed la web je
voulais là et qui sont soupçonnés de lui
avoir notamment fourni des armes la
comparaison de ses accusés qui font
figure de compares de Mohamed Bruel
permettra-t-elle victime de penser leur
plaît libération précise qu'aucun
d'entre eux n'est jugé pour complicité
mais que ceci était selon l'accusation
en tout cas pleinement conscient de
l'adhésion récent du meurtrier à
l'idéologie du djihad et de sa
fascination pour les passages à des
passages à l'acte violent bien avant sa
radicalisation permet de là où il y a je
voulais avait déjà eu affaire à la
justice et en particulier pour des faits
de violence conjugales on a eu également
des journaux ce matin le rejet par plus
de 60% des Chiliens du projet de
nouvelle Constitution ce projet il
devait remplacer le texte en vigueur
depuis la dictature de stopinochet
d'après le site eldescondes le président
de gauche Gabriel borique ici à l'image
qui soutenait ce projet présenté comme
très progressiste s'est engagé malgré
tout à poursuivre le projet de
rénovation constitutionnelle le chef de
l'État a également promis un remaniement
ministériel et provoqué l'ensemble est
convoqué pardon l'ensemble des parties
politiques pour discuter de la suite
mais selon la tfca qui est un autre site
chilien le résultat du référendum d'hier
est indédiablement un coup dur pour
Gabriel Boric selon l'édition latino
américaine du quotidien espagnol El Pais
ce résultat sanctionne aussi la gestion
du gouvernement actuel et le président
est désormais condamné au politique pour
essayer de piloter à nouveau et plus
large processus constituant à
l'Assemblée c'est à propos de gestion de
gouvernement critiqué au Royaume-Uni la
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
étrangères l'istre et donner favorite
pour succéder à Boris Johnson alors que
vous l'avez dit le résultat du vote des
militants qu'on s'arrêteurs ne sera
connu que dans une poignée d'or via
présente déjà listrals comme la première
ministre en attente une nouvelle chef du
gouvernement qui se targue d'incarner
l'orthodoxe libéral dans le sillage de
feu Margaret Thatcher comme un témoigne
cette citation contre ce matin la une du
gardien voir les choses à travers le
prisme de la redistribution est une
mauvaise chose aider les plus riches et
juste je les cite un ultra libéralisme
que les stress semble tempérer néanmoins
dans d'autres déclarations notamment sur
la possibilité de geler prochainement
les factures d'électricité pour les
ménages les plus pauvres pour éviter un
Armageddon énergétique mais que que veut
réellement les stress a d'abord opposé
on s'en souvient au brexit avant de d'en
devenir une ardente promotrice dans le
dessin publié par The Times de Morton
Morlon avec moi ce que vous voyez c'est
ce que vous savez ce que vous avez la
question étant évidemment de savoir ce
qu'on voit vraiment oui avec une
perruque de margadet sur quelque part je
sens qu'on va pas s'ennuyer du côté des
carrés tu risques britanniques à nouveau
un mot à présent cette enquête du monde
le journal Le Monde qui consacre une
enquête aux Marchand de Sable pas se
charger l'endormir les enfants qui
laisse tomber du sable sur leurs yeux
pas du tout cet excellente enquête sur
l'exploitation effrénée de ce qui est
après l'eau la deuxième ressource
naturelle la plus consommée au monde une
consommation qui s'envole d'ailleurs
alors qu'elle s'établissait déjà à plus
de 3 milliards de tonnes en 2020 cette
enquête donc raconte sur six épisodes
les ravages écologiques mais aussi
économiques et sociétaux de cette
consommation effrénée première épisode à
retrouver dès aujourd'hui en Inde ou
l'exploitation du sable et aux mains de
mafia qui non seulement des pratiques
qui entraînent des violences et des
meurtres mais aussi évidemment des
dégâts écologiques majeurs voilà et
retrouver notamment sur l'édition en
ligne du monde avec des images animées
enfin bref un webdoc très intéressant on
se quitte pas là-dessus il ne faut
jamais désespérer de rien n'est-ce pas
Damien Le Figaro relay en tout cas
l'histoire extraordinaire de Romualdo
Macédo Rodrigues ce pêcheur brésilien
fait naufrage le mois dernier dans
l'Atlantique et bien que ne sachant pas
nager il a réussi à survivre 11 jours en
pleine mer en trouvant un refuge
figurez-vous dans un congélateur qui se
trouvait à bord de son embarcation en
rentrant chez lui Romualdo massédor
Rodriguez ça remercie la Providence ce
réfrigérateur pour moi c'était Dieu un
vrai miracle justement merci beaucoup
Hélène